مشهد مهيب صور لكل ايراني قتل على يد
النظام الايراني منذ عام
1988 حتى اليوم وضعتها المعارضه الايرانيه
في واشنطن في حديقه امام مبنى الكونجرس في
خطوه تهدف الى وضع مزيد من الضغوط على
الاداره الامريكيه للوقوف الى جانب الشعب
الايراني في مواجهه النظام
اولا نريد ان نظهر الفضاء التي ارتكبها
النظام منذ 40 عاما ويستمر بارتكابها حتى
اليوم ثانيا نود ان نظهر الشجاعه والمرونه
اللتين يظهرهما شبابنا الذين خرجوا
لمواجهه النظام الديكتاتوريه
حركه الاحتجاجات بعد وفاه مساء اماني
تصعدت المخاوف من تطبيق عشرات احكام
الاعدام صدرت ضد المعتقلين من المتظاهرين
بم عامه قال المعارضون انها سوريه ولا
يسمح للسجناء بالدفاع عن انفسهم او حتى
باختيار فريق للدفاع عنهم تماما مثل شقيقه
تارا شافعي الذي اعدمه النظام من دون
محاكمه ومن دون ان تتمكن عائلته من رؤيته
لا اريد اي عائله ايرانيه
لقد دمرنا هذا النظام وشردنا خارج ارضنا
انا ارى وجهه بكلها هؤلاء الشباب الذين
نزلوا الى الشوارع ليتظاهر ضد هذا النظام
وانا خائفه على مصيرهم لهذا السبب انا هنا
كانت محكمه الثوره الايرانيه المتظاهرين
محسن شكاري ومجيد رضا رهن ورد بيتهامي حمل
السلاح واقلاق راحه المواطنين دول عديده
نددت بتنفيذ الحكم وتردت الامم المتحده
ايران من لجنه حقوق المراه بسبب ممارستها
ضد المحتاجين
الف صوره وصوره وضحايا النظام يتساقطون
واحدا تلو الاخر هذا ما يقوله المعارضون
الايرانيون في واشنطن الذين يواجهون رساله
الى الاداره الامريكيه لحسها على منع
النظام الايراني من تنفيذ عشرات احكام
الاعدام التي اصدرها بحق المعارضين في
ايران
العربيه واشنطن